collecting milk bottles following brown
road songs spotting village water pumps
taking pictures of tombstones
appreciating roundabouts these are dull
things to do aren't they
welcome to the delmond's club I am
Grover click I'm assistant vice
president the dull men's club and one of
its founders the dolmens club is a group
of that gift together to celebrate the
ordinary and began in the 1980s long
time ago we began in New York City and
later I moved to London and the dull
men's club followed me and has grown
here in England as well it's got members
both in England and America and across
the world the last time we did a roundup
putting all things together looked like
that about 5,000 members so here are the
people that do things that some people
think are dull here's Steve I'm a mobile
collector have some 20,000 mill poles
from not just the UK but all over the
world Germany France South Africa Hong
Kong Portugal I've got Iranian bottles
I'd like milk at all I just don't like
it sorry
and we have some women that are
interested in the dole men's club here's
Amanda my quirky hobby is randomly
following Graham surest signs yep you
heard her right I get inspired to turn
off the road whenever I see one I find
it very hard not to I follow Browne
signs around the UK and indeed the whole
world so I've now been to thousands and
thousands we also have a member that
appreciates roundabouts I'm Kevin and
I'm the president of the UK roundabout
appreciation society also known as Lord
of the Rings that's my official title I
have taken thousands of pictures of
roundabouts even when I'm abroad on
holiday and now a lot of people would
find my hobby quite don't but it's
bright being dull it's sexy being dull
and next is a member that is just dying
to get into a graveyard
I'm a tube traveler and I take pictures
of famous graves around the globe
probably at least four or five hundred
on various parts of the world Kennedy
Martin Luther King Bruce Lee and Brandon
Lee Elvis Presley Ludwig van Beethoven
Charlie Chaplin well I don't feel that
on a doorman but people have said that
but I prefer to think that I've got
around it I'll be an interest to takes
my mind away from work and we have deck
through spotting village water pumps and
they all came about two accidents ten
years ago somebody pointed out a tiny
little pump by the side of the road and
almost every village we went to I'd
suppose because it's and the brakes on
the jump out and take a picture of the
pump it's okay to be dull a lot of
studies being done now that boredom is
got benefit we're not so interested in
the glitz and glam we're quite happy
with simple things in life